e
e e
good morning everyone welcome to the
criminal justice committee if you please
rise and join me for the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag unit States of America and to the
rep for it stands one nation under God
indivisible with
li thank you for everyone who took the
time out of their schedules to come in
today to address the members we really
appreciate that um we have a lot of new
members this year who aren't familiar
with criminal justice or perhaps not
with the way our committee works and we
have a lot of attorney members who have
been doing this for years but we like
seeing you so We're Glad You Came um so
I have a list of everyone who's in who
came today um but I'm going to start
with the person who I think is most
important or I see the Chief Justice he
was very busy if um if you'd like to go
ahead and start the court we we be happy
to good morning Mr chairman members of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity and your time I understand
10 minutes 15 minutes whatever you need
okay we prepared some slides um and
they're being circulated
so
um while the slides are going around I
do want to introduce Aon krian who is
the general counsel to the judicial
branch and I know she's well known to at
least the veteran members of this
committee uh and we both stand ready as
you undertake your work this year to
assist the committee in its work the
objective of my presentation today is
really to give uh committee members an
overview of our state justice system the
Judiciary in the state of New Hampshire
so that's that's what I'm here to talk
about and I'm please interrupt with any
questions as we go along so uh page
three please uh it's an overview of my
presentation one structure of the
judicial branch and two uh the
challenges and opportunities that we
face next slide slide
four uh on on the left you see a a
visual representation of the structure
of the judicial branch we have two trial
courts the circuit court and the
Superior Court we have one appell Court
which is the Supreme Court and all three
courts are supported by the administrat
of Office of the courts and I'm going to
take a minute to go through each one of
those elements starting with the circuit
court on the next Slide the Circuit
Court was created by this legislature in
2011 it combined The District Court the
probate court and the Family Division uh
into one
unit on the next slide you will see that
the circuit court is broken into 10
circuits one for each County and we have
34 individual locations around the
state on the next slide you will see
that right now our head count is 49
Circuit Court judges that is our
authorized
um uh number at this point we are fully
um staffed with judges those judges
those full-time judges their work is
supplemented by one part-time
judge uh two perdum judges and some
judge judicial referees and Senior
active judges who are able to discharge
judicial functions subject to the
ultimate approval of a sitting Circuit
Judge so that's how the workflow gets
handled by Jud judicial officers in the
circuit court next next slide perhaps
the most um one of the more important
ones is the amount of number of cases
flowing through our Circuit Court these
are 2023 calendary year numbers uh
102,000 cases and you'll see at the very
top of that Circle of interest to this
committee 45,000 criminal cases this is
before the felonies first re unwind so
these numbers that 45,000 are the the
misdemeanors that the circuit court has
jurisdiction over Superior Court has
jurisdiction over felonies Circuit Court
misdemeanors so this number is going to
be revised uh as uh to reflect felonies
first I just don't have those numbers
right
now next slide uh Superior Court
Superior Court is our court of General
jurisdiction in New
Hampshire uh of relevance to this
committee it is the court where jury
trials take place and is the court where
all felonies are prosecuted it also has
uh civil jurisdiction for uh cases over
$255,000 on the next slide you will see
the breakdown of our case load by case
type and again on the left in the yellow
about 8,700 criminal cases flow through
spe court and again these are 2023
numbers uh both courts both circuit and
Superior Court handle felony um handle
search warrant and arrest warrant
requests from law enforcement agencies
around the state so that's part of the
jurisdiction of both of our trial
courts next slide uh we have 11 Superior
Courts one in each County two in
Hillsboro one in Ash and one in
Manchester our Superior Court uh bench
is likewise fully U staffed at this
moment we're authorized at 22 two
associate justices and one chief
justice next slide of particular
interest to this committee given its
work on House Bill
318 uh earlier this or uh in December we
uh took on three new
magistrates and on January 1st they
began their work and uh their
jurisdiction as um directed by
administrative order the Supreme Court
is listed here uh they have been uh
fully trained by uh judges from both
courts and their weekend Duty which was
the principal a principal motivating
reason for creating magistrates not the
only one um began on the first weekend
in January so the our three magistrates
are switching off weekend by weekend
they serve 9 to one on each of the
weekend days and then on the weekday
they are integrating into our uh trial
courts to assist uh with matters that
they're authorized to handle in our
trial
courts next Slide the Supreme Court as I
said one appell Court in New Hampshire
that's the Supreme Court uh we have one
chief justice for associate justices in
addition to hearing appeals we have
General super superintending authority
over the legal profession in New
Hampshire and therefore we handle
matters such as attorney discipline um a
bar admission
uh and we um we interface regularly with
the bar association we are unified bar
in New Hampshire which means every every
lawyer in New Hampshire is required to
be a member of The Bar Next slide you
will see our
um case load these numbers on your slide
are for 2023 and I do want to um give
you some numbers from 2024 the year that
obviously just finished uh so um
you'll see in 2023 we issued 61 opinions
that number for 2024 is
71 the bottom number is the key
indicator of our
productivity and um in
2023 it was 728 dispositions in 2024 was
752 and that's the highest number in our
court since 2015 so our productivity is
is at a high level over the last 10
years for for last
year could you just real quick um tell
the members what a final disposition
means those so every case that comes
into our system uh will be handled
either through a full-blown
argument or through case uh through
orders issued by the four the five
justices coming together and in some
instances we will decline jurisdiction
where jurisdiction is not mandatory so
the dispositions is is how many of the
cases that came into our system are
actually resolved one way or another by
the Supreme
Court uh very quickly we are all on the
next slide supported by the
administrative office of the courts and
then uh uh slide 18 you can see the
various important functions performed by
the AOC including our legal and
legislative representation uh I should
have mentioned of Harris is here as our
director of communications uh and
various other functions that help uh
assist the court staff and judges around
the state are handled by the AOC very
quickly I'd like to share with the
committee some of our both challenges
and
opportunities um next slide is
20 um and I want to go through each one
of these very very briefly but you can
see our challenges and opportunities
listed there 21 challenge number one and
um it is the is is that I am most
concerned with it's the issue that keeps
me up at night more than any other which
is the Safety and Security of everyone
who passes through our
doors and um we have made important
strides over the last several years in
terms of enhancing that Safety and
Security um we have benefited from uh
arpa dollars the that the governor
sonunu uh his office helped uh make
available to the judicial branch and and
one of one of the projects we are
undertaking is a sight by sight physical
assessment of security threats and
security uh enhancement opportunities
for each one of our locations I will say
uh um we our security is sort of
bifurcated in circuit courts uh it's
handled by uh court security officers
who are employees of the judicial branch
work in the AOC and we are greatly
benefited in in Superior Court with a
tremendous partnership from the
sheriff's County Sheriffs who are in
charge of security in our Superior Court
and I want to acknowledge and thank that
partnership it's absolutely essential in
keeping our everyone who passes through
our doors uh
safe uh next challenge not really uh of
concern to this committee's jurisdiction
but I do want to note it in in Superior
Court uh the influx of cases arising
from the YDC matter has been
significant and uh 1 1300 filings in
Superior Court against as you saw a case
load of 24,000 it's material and it's
material also because these cases are
quite complex they generate a lot of
motions they consume a lot of court time
and a lot of Staff time indeed if chief
justice Howard we're here he will tell
you he's got an employee in the
electronic filing Center in Manchester
who comes in at 4 uh 5:00 in the morning
to process all the all the Motions
involved in the YDC
cases um the next challenge is access to
Justice and this is sort of a perennial
challenge uh facing our judicial system
not sort of it is and uh in any given
day walking into our Circuit Court up to
90% of litigants on either side of the
case are self-represented
uh one issue that I do want to call to
the attention of this committee that is
quite serious is is what I think is
fairly described as a crisis in our
indigen defense system uh indigen
defense is principally handled in our
state by the New Hampshire Public
Defenders Office uh that is a publicly
funded organization since 2010 it has
had a 262 per increase in its retention
uh dropping in retention uh and that's
augmented by uh increased case load and
case loads that are more sophisticated
and they're more sophisticated because a
reason is because the proliferation of
electronic evidence particularly video
evidence um Mo many of our law
enforcement officers are now having body
cams and obviously uh video cameras are
are much more of a reality of law
enforcement so this is contributing to
the case load um contributing to the
workload in our public defender
office this affects the entire Criminal
Justice
System criminal defendants are entitled
to representation under both the state
and federal
Constitution and uh you will see that
the LBA issued a report on the judicial
Council last October and found that in
March of 2024 between 20 and 40
incarcerated defendants had no attorney
in between 120 100 and 125
non-incarcerated so these are
constitutional rights that are in play
and when when uh the accused don't have
attorneys it affects us in the court
system for obvious reasons we can't
proceed with the case and um there it it
affects the entire
system um that said we're also making
progress thanks in part to the
legislative initiatives on um on the
Civil side the legislature approved
approved a bill to permit par
professionals to represent clients in
designated case types in our Circuit
Court every Circuit Court in the state
we're implementing that program and
we're pleased by the results so far
another opportunity is our treatment
courts uh we the adult drug court has
been uh in place legislatively sponsored
for more than 10 years um we have mental
health courts in both Superior and
circuit courts uh the legislature
approved last year in new veterans court
and uh we're working on a homeless Court
initiative with the mayor Manchester to
try uh to assist in in resolving those
problems broadly speaking treatment
courts are an
opportunity um to identify those in our
system who would
benefit from treatment in a clinically
appropriate setting so that they don't
come back into our system that's broadly
speaking our objective
uh the commissioner Corrections is here
she's been a tremendous assistance in uh
both our treatment court and mental
health court initiatives but also the
next opportunity I want to talk about
which is a broad judicial branch
initiative to look at how we can better
serve those in our community suffering
from mental
illness
uh the slide 26 begins just couple
slides on innovation we we are we try to
use the resources we have as efficiently
as possible um one great example is
landlord tenant um there are more than
7,000 cases in circuit court on landlord
tenant and thanks to some federal
dollars where we've been able to
establish a diversion program with a
great success rate so it it gets
resolution to both the landlords and the
tenants and it reduces the case load in
in our system uh next slide 27 in our
Superior Court we are moving to a
platform where all evidence is
electronically presented and their their
efficiencies to the court and to the
attorneys involved on both sides and
then finally um we're using technology
particularly tax uh to on both civil and
criminal side in both of our courts uh
for
reminders understanding that that's how
many of the people we serve receive
information it's very very successful in
reducing failure to appear
rates so with that that's a very broad
overview happy to answer any questions
you will have my contact information and
that of Aaron on the last page and uh we
look forward to engaging with the
committee over the next year and thank
you very much Mr chairman for the
opportunity thank you for coming Mr
chief justice do any of the members have
questions um I I have one myself have
has the bar looked at um
possibly as a condition of membership
mandating so many pro or hours to indent
defendants per
year
um and I don't mean to put you on the
spot um I think mandate is is with
respect to pro bono hours or or
delivering there there is an
encouragement to to to engage in prooo
activity but a mandate is it's not
required right okay um but I will say Mr
chairman
um uh at least since I've been there uh
2021 this crisis has been percolating
yeah and uh one of the things that the
Supreme Court did was
convene uh the large firms in our state
to say we've got we've got a real
problem in our engine defense system we
need attorneys to step up
and help and I will say the response was
extraordinary okay and we were able on a
volunteer basis to get attorneys from
many many of our uh firms around the
state to come into the system and assist
with this issue and are they still doing
that yes oh that's good to hear I'm glad
I'd rather not talk about me and they
just doing it um one other question I
had has the court explored any kind of a
partnership with UNH law whereby someone
could get some some um tuition waved if
they dedicate so many
hours
um to to my knowledge no um but and I
know the chair is very interested in
this and you communicated to to uh
General Council krian about this it's
it's an issue of great interest to me
nationally yeah there are some really
interesting initiatives around the
country about granting tuition
conditioned upon serving the you know
delivering pro bono hours in
particularly addressing a problem that
is uh existing in virtually every state
which are called rural legal deserts
yeah where there are just vast swas of
geography with less than one attorney
for 1,000 residents wow and and for
instance in South Dakota there there's a
really interesting pilot Pro uh program
they're piloting which does exactly as
you're suggesting so there there is
there's lots of interest and energy
around the country about this and and I
think it's a it's a conversation worth
worth following and having good that's
great to hear I think um we should take
advantage of the fact that we own a law
school I think so I think that's a um
something I'd like to pursue that's
great thank you but I will say that the
loss we we do benefit from it I know in
my opinion uh really forward thinking
law school which is heavily engaged in
our community and for instance the
Daniel Webster scholar honors program uh
true Jewel of our estate um does with
those attorneys young attorneys they
undergo the first year of curriculum of
any law student and then spend the
second two years doing what's basically
an experiential learning program under
specialized uh curriculum developed in
partnership with the Supreme Court part
of that experience is delivering pro
bono hours oh that's good including to
victims of domestic violence and the and
the bar association stealth program
that's that's excellent I'm glad you
shared that with US Representative s you
had a
question no well I'm sorry she used to
sit there it's okay it's a it's a good
person to be confused with um I was just
curious I I had uh met with folks from
603 legal aid um and also um New
Hampshire legal aid uh two two SE
programs but they kind of work together
and and serve different um um you know
demographics of folks um and so I was
just wondering when people do pro bono
is that the main um institution that
they do it through or organization that
they would do pro bono hours with uh pro
bono opportunities there there there're
many many of them are offered through
New Hampshire legal assistance and and
603 legal is really the hub for a hub
now for coordinating the pro bono
program and
um but it's not necessarily the only no
but they they um screen clients and then
find appropriate opportunities for
lawyers it's not necessarily the only
opportunity to deliver pro bono hours
they are important ones and they they're
designed to make pro bono uh work for
attorneys sort of create an easy button
for them if you will um and for instance
if
uh they work closely with a domestic
violence um Dove program domestic
violence emergency program and and
getting lawyers trained up and um and
involved in that program so it's it's to
answer your question really really
really important but not necessarily the
only opportunity for for lawyers thank
you thank you again for your time I
don't believe anyone else has any
questions thank you Mr chair yeah go
ahead um
good morning members of the committee my
name is Aon K I'm the general counsel
for the court system I will try to
follow the Chief Justice very briefly
just to introduce myself to new members
I'm going to leave a a little stack of
business cards right next to
representative Murphy who I'm not
favoring only because she represents my
parents in marac um but uh it's going to
have my cell on it please feel free to
email me call me text me with any
questions any information that you need
from the judicial branch in order to do
your legislative job uh many members of
the judicial branch are adjudication
during the day but I am a single point
of contact I will get you the
information that you need from anywhere
in the judicial branch please feel free
to reach out to me I'm also available to
come to hearings if you need to have um
someone from the branch part of the
discussion let me know um I'll appear
when a legislator requests for us to be
present uh so I just want to introduce
myself and uh please feel free to reach
out to me anytime thank you very much I
would just tell the members that if you
or any of your colleagues are
considering legislation that will impact
the Judiciary that is just Source right
there to talk to before you put pen to
paper because you may end up rewriting
something because it won't work and
she'll tell you in advance whether or
not it'll work thank you also these um
handouts from the Chief Justice hold on
to these um there's a lot of good
information in here when you go to write
bills or even look at the bills that are
coming to us browse through that and you
may find answers to questions thank you
again um now we have the Attorney
General's office
I thought I saw the general here did he
leave excuse me sorry he's just getting
back from a trip from DC so he's not
available to attend today um good
morning members of the committee my name
is Matt Broadhead I'm an associate
attorney general um I'm the head of the
division of legal council and good
morning Mr chair members of the
committee my name is Thomas fardi I am
also an associate attorney general I am
the director of the division of public
protection which includes criminal
consumer and environmental
bureaus and so together we represent
kind of the uh we oversee all of the
attorney operations at the Department of
Justice um my division uh has seven
units and bureaus U we uh have the
litigation unit in the Civil Bureau the
client counseling unit which provides
agency advice to all of the state
agencies except for two um the other two
are um attached to the public safety and
infrastructure Bureau those are a
highway funded agencies and so that
Bureau is also Highway funded um and the
um uh so I oversee that Bureau as well
as the charitable trust unit the debt
Recovery Unit uh the Civil Rights unit
and the election law unit um so that's
kind of the functions that all kind of
report up through me and um Tom gave a
brief overview of of his bureaus um is
there anything else you want to say
about your bureaus just for the purposes
of this committee so criminal is broken
into several different units just as uh
associate Broadhead just articulated for
his side of the house criminal includes
uh first and foremost a homicide unit
then there is um a drug unit there's a
public Integrity unit uh there's
Medicaid fraud unit uh
and uh we have a special unit devoted to
the YDC litigation cases so those are
just within the criminal justice Bureau
um and um some of the different
operations that are contained in that
which
um from time to time I will come and
talk to you about there might be
legislation touching on um some of those
topics and in terms of my um the areas
where uh our my division might overlap
with your committee work would be really
we provide general counsel to State
Police the department of safety so
there's issues that come up with the
motor vehicle code um issues that come
up with um you know immunities that
State uh uh um uh agencies and uh
employees um have during the course of
civil litigation those are types of
issues that um our litigation unit our
Public Safety and infrastructure Bureau
would be interested in looking at um in
terms of legislative issues when we do
review legislation we obviously get
fiscal note requests for anything that
might impact the agency operations so we
pride we try to provide an honest and
Frank assessment of what we think the
impact would be to the to the Department
um outside of that um we generally
because we're obligated as the
Department of Justice to uh defend and
enforce any law that the legislature
passes that's signed by the governor we
tend not to weigh in too much on
substantive policy um because we don't
want our words to be used against us in
some sort of lawsuit um later on so um
we but we we take our job seriously
we're um we maintain the independence we
we it doesn't matter we're party blind
in terms of once legislation is passed
and becomes enacted into the law it's
our job to enforce
it would you be a good resource for
members to contact if they had a
question about legislation that they
were thinking about bringing before it
actually becomes
law uh absolutely Tom and I um we would
be the ones that would kind of Marshal
any sort of leg legislative response um
or response to the legislature um
anything touching the criminal code Tom
would handle anything affecting the
Department of Justice operations would
most likely be
me any questions from the
members seeing none I thank you for your
time and coming over here today we'll
see you shortly I'm sure yeah I
know um commissioner Hanks
I apologize commissioner I didn't
realize you had to go I just now saw
this note that said that you were in a
so I would have called you first uh no
apology uh necessary I appreciate it
um I've been uh working for a long time
so I had to check the clock I've been in
the prison this morning so uh good
morning honorable chair members of the
committee uh it is a pleasure to be here
again uh for the record my name is Helen
Hanks I'm the commissioner of the
Department of Corrections to my right is
Jane Graham she is our strategic uh
Communications administrator and our
legislative liaison so um to some of the
questions already asked this morning if
you have uh pending legislation or
questions around legislation you might
pass if you'll direct them to Jane and
we'll make sure uh we get all of our
contact information to the committee we
happy to both give you statistics that
will inform your legis ation which has
often been a resource and um follow up
on any impacts to the department to
assist you as you navigate your service
to the state of New Hampshire the packet
before you I apologize does not have
page numbers it's a series of
information uh intended to give you a
good Baseline of what the organization
does on behalf of the Department of
Corrections what our mission and vision
is that's the first and uh foremost
which is a balance between uh Public
Safety and Rehabilitation while ensuring
that we provide the Humane custody
supervision and control of individuals
sent uh to incarceration and supervision
under probation parole in state of New
Hampshire the second page is our value
statement as a department uh we revised
these some years ago uh to make sure
that our staff were involved in
articulating what we do every day um and
I just want to point out one of them uh
it takes one team in our department to
be successful we have a large law
enforcement officer Cadre in addition to
the same number of professional that
each one of our community needs to be
successful nursing staff mental health
staff uh certified Educators so on and
so forth on the following uh page you'll
see our large uh departmental
organizational structure um including
our housing units in an overview of
those um not pointed out here but should
be pointed out here is we have 11
district offices across the state of New
Hampshire where our probation approval
officers do their fine work in our New
Hampshire
communities um now it gets into the next
page my favorite cuz I love data uh that
is something you'll learn about me this
is our current uh data of who is
incarcerated in the state of New
Hampshire in our facilities um out of
our facilities means they are out of
state in another facility being
supervised um just so you understand
what that means I always like to provide
the number of individuals by minimum uh
sentence structure in the State uh we'll
tell you uh by way of information I've
been with the Department um on my 22nd
year there has been a shift in
sentencing that's not a judgment
statement that's just a reality the
average sentence structure was 3 and 1
half to 7 now it's pushing closer to
five or more years um the reason for
that is we have a large population of
individuals who have uh violated
criminal code around sexual assault and
so those sentences are longer for uh
correct reasons and then the next uh
data set is around people's maximum
sentence structures one thing we can
never control for in reporting data to
all of you is whether somebody has a
consecutive sentence we can't predict
their moving movement into that
consecutive sentence so this is a
snapshot based on what people are
serving at the time of the data
set uh the
following page uh shows you the trending
of uh bookings into our facilities uh we
break it out uh by month uh we look at
uh men and women we do monitor um
incarceration rates it does matter we do
look for overcrowding and need to pay
attention to the number of beds we're
utilizing in comparison to the staff we
have to make sure we provide the
appropriate supervision that's the data
set on that page the following page
breaks out the the demographics of those
incarcerated in the state of New
Hampshire and in very broad groups on
the bottom of the page breaks out their
um very detailed crime into higher
categories of crime so you'll see the
largest percent in New Hampshire are
crimes against persons I've already
articulated that and then other assaults
and things of that nature
have you ever looked at how we stack up
against the other states with these
crimes against persons um that's a
wonderful question uh chairman and the
answer to that is uh yes um uh we have a
higher rate of individuals incarcerated
for sexual assault in the state of New
Hampshire um about one-third of our
men's population are in for either
aggravated fonia sexual assault or fonia
sexual assault um in comparison to other
states what I have found nationally is
they generally plea their cases is down
so those that are incarcerated for
similar offenses in other states end up
under I would call it our parallel
category of second degree assault so
their sexual assault rates look lower
whereas our uh prosecutors prosecute to
the
fullest thank you um it also provides me
an opportunity to let you know that we
are ranked number one uh in the country
for Corrections and crime and what that
means is we have a very low national uh
crime rate in comparison to other states
and we actually are one of the only
states that have a reduced incarceration
rate and so from my vantage point
leading the organization through the
pandemic when States chose um to let
people out before their minimum sentence
structure we did not um the work we've
done in our state uh with the Chief
Justice uh on the Judiciary side with
specialty courts have positively
impacted appropriate diversion from
incarceration um and we've really been
Nimble before the pandemic to effectuate
a reduction in the use of incarceration
where appropriate
uh welcome commissioner nice to see you
sir um I'm I'm looking at the
demographic page and the the 60 the uh
population by age and the 60 and over
category which
is larger than I thought it would be but
you know it doesn't matter um how many
you're safe representative you're
okay um how many uh of those 60 and over
are serving life without parole
sentences uh represent share I can't
give you that number on age what I can
tell you is we have approximately 100
individuals who will never leave our
custody because their sent in structure
I just don't have it broken out by age
break and a follow-up question U
at would it be fair to say that the
medical costs uh for the over 60
population
are more significant than the younger
population as we're talking about about
age I want to be careful because in
incarceration um the costs around
healthc care actually start to increase
for individuals who are 51 and over so
to the point uh of your question yes
healthc care costs increase based on age
but it starts at the at the lower uh one
step down demographic range um and I can
give you some followup of the average
healthc care cost by age range and last
question um roughly uh what does it cost
uh per person to incarcerate someone for
a year approximately $452 a day was our
last statistic thanks thank you you're
welcome representative
Murray thank you Mr chair nice to see
you again commissioner as well um in the
past couple years you know i' obviously
done a lot of research in you know your
work um and I believe some statistics I
saw over the past couple years um
Illustrated us having a really high rate
of um violations and people being in
prison because of parle violations I was
just wondering if that's true if you
could speak to that at all certainly I
can speak to that now or I could speak
to it when I get to those slides happy
to do when you get to it yeah and if
anyone has what was your question go
ahead I just have a question about the
importance of the sentence of a year or
a year in a day and how you have 46
people that are there and how some
people go to jails and some people go to
prison uh thank you for that question
yes uh individuals that that you'll see
on this uh the previous page on sentence
structure when it's one year or less
they go to our County jails if an
individual in our County Jail system has
multiple consecutive misdemeanor charges
of the statute as it currently States at
the
366th day they would come to the
Department of Corrections and we work
with our County Superintendent on those
decisions uh when those decisions happen
if we work together and say they're
better served staying in the county jail
maybe it's 345 days they have to serve
uh the Department of Corrections pays
back to the county jail U the average
daily cost of that person's
incarceration so I think that's your
answer to your question you're
welcome all right average cost by
Healthcare by age following page I want
to thank the legislature for your
support uh several years ago um through
the budgeting process and the reality a
of our law enforcement ranks in the
Department of Corrections this slide uh
shows you the where we were and in the
bottom uh right hand corner shows you
where we uh rank as far as
competitiveness across law enforcement
in the state um and uh it's made great
strides I'll send some follow-up data uh
at our worst point we had over a 50%
vacancy rate in our correction officer
rank and file we've done a tremendous
job over the last year in reducing that
to 42%
um these are Nimble numbers so one or
two losses shift them but what that
means is at the highest point we had
approximately 189 vacancies out of 589
opportunities and now we're down closer
to 162 or less um those uh are net gains
to the organization and in 2022 we had a
high rate of retirement from our system
welld deserved post the pandemic and the
stress in a correctional environment and
that's also normalized itself where we
had historically seen a anywhere between
15 and a high of 20 people retiring we
back to that normative uh departure rate
at retirement and the same separation
rate when it people self- select uh to
leave our employment that number is
normalized and I'll send some update
numbers with that regard what that means
is that being said you guys aren't
you're not fully staffed you're still a
mess right with the staff thank you sir
I was about to say with that being said
uh we are we are still um working very
hard against the same tide that our
other law enforce Partners experience in
the state of New Hampshire and I'm I'm
proud of our state the expectation to
join the ranks of law enforcement are
the same across all lines of those
opportunities whether you're a community
police officer a State Trooper so on and
so so forth and a corrections officer
and we hold that standard and we hold
that standard on purpose um because
there's a lot of authority and integrity
and so while we're all competing against
all of those same entry level people
trying to attract people to come into
Corrections and I think we're doing a
much better job to explain why that
mission is so important but um I have to
tell you if I was a young person and I
was going into law enforcement I'd pick
a cruiser in my freedom in the community
um because I wouldn't have known all
that I know now um but uh we actually
today started the day with approximately
25 of our staff who have stepped up and
uh said they want to voluntarily be part
of our Recruitment and Retention efforts
as ambassadors of Correction so we need
your help uh any opportunity to include
us in any uh legislation on recruitment
of law enforcement we want to be part of
that legislatively um and we want to sh
the ship because we also know
fundamentally we cost the state of New
Hampshire a lot of money to fulfill our
mission when we're looking at $27
million in overtime that is the burden
that our Corrections Officers are facing
every day and we've done a lot of
creative things within the scope of our
operations to give them a chance to go
home and use other relief resources but
uh the cost of um our staff is
significant to the general fund dollar
maybe I should just stop there I don't
know sorry sir moving on I wanted to
move into the other side the
rehabilitation and treatment side of the
organization and so on this next slide
uh give you a tenor of the work that our
mental health clinicians are doing by
area total number of appointments uh
total number of clients served in those
appointments and cross different lines
of uh mental health contact but our
mental health team is really uh working
very hard to treat the diagnosed
illnesses of individuals incarcerated in
the state of New Hampshire to meet the
Constitutional requirements that we are
required to do but also to find Wellness
in individuals and to reduce and we'll
get to it representative Murray that
reincarceration rate due to uh parole
violations and um that's an important
part of our conversation with you today
the following slide just lists a very
high overview um of the uh outpatient we
call them outpatient no they're not
leaving the institution but they're not
in a um call a psychiatric bed in the
secure psychiatric unit they're moving
from their housing unit to the mental
health floor within the corrections unit
and these are the services in a high
level that we offer within the
department included in those Services is
um we've gotten creative in how we use
our housing units and created modified
therapeutic communities within our
department of corrections and what
that's done is uh allowed individuals
who acknowledge their mental illness who
want to come together and become U more
compliant with their treatment um
increase their skill sets and coping
skills around that and that's made a
marked difference in those housing units
when you literally come together with a
common purpose uh I don't think we'd be
surprised you get better um and so the
following sheet are infographics that
we're trying to put together to both
educate um anybody who we can have
listen to us about the work we do and
one of those units is the focus unit we
have a high prevalence rate of
individuals with substance use disorder
incarcerated in the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections um and we need
to tackle those challenges with the
relapse and the impact act on
individuals um in the justice system
this program was implemented many some
some years ago and is showing a marked
stride in reducing returns to
incarceration and um I'll leave it to
you I know you'll read it and if you
want followup uh we'll engage in that
followup the other units we talk about
are called Wellness units and we have an
intensive sexual offender treatment
service you're going to see a slide that
looks like
this um this slide is u a result of
working with the council state
governments and trying to understand
specifically the rate of opioid use
disorder that we're treating in the
Department of Corrections so on any
given day in our department we have
approximately 45% of people incarcerated
who have an opioid use disorder that's
around 800 people of those 800
individuals uh 32 excuse me of those 800
individuals 80% of them have elected to
be on some form of treatment a
medication assisted treatment and we
have a robust program in which we engage
in that constitutional treatment
intervention as well this slide was also
very informative because it taught us
the work we were doing as a department
connecting people to Medicaid so thank
you for um authorizing Medicaid
expansion uh it has positively impacted
individuals incarcerated in their exit
and we're really connecting them to that
service and it's making a difference and
they're using those Services upon
release within 7 Days Of release in the
community and connecting for their
substance use treatment their pharmace
pH ceuticals and other treatment
interventions and so that my the segue
leads me to another
infographic we the state uh remitted
what's called an 1115a re-entry waiver
to the Center for Medicaid Medicare
Services we were approved for that
waiver and we started on January 1st
2025 with the authorization 45 days
prior to someone's release when they're
Medicaid eligible we can have two
provider contacts and two peer-to-peer
contacts and Medicaid will cover 30 days
of discharge medications and I believe
very firmly that this initiative will
decrease people's returns to
incarceration and so I I leave you with
a what I call is a highlevel infographic
and we can get down into uh lots of
detail at your uh personal
discretion critical to the success of
that program um and even the work that
we do as our case management services so
I've given you a highle slide of our
case managers what they do the areas
that they support individuals
and they're going to be critical as they
are now in helping people apply for
Medicaid have those uh appointments
scheduled and have those contacts prior
to
release the following page gets into the
detail of the risk assessment tool this
is a risk of residivis assessment tool
this is not a risk of violence or those
clinical risk assessments people talk
about this is literally specific to
criminogenic factors and your risk of
return to incarceration so I outline
that in a high level W for you on the
next slide our case management team does
what we call internal referrals to other
areas of the department as well as
external referrals to Partners in the
community I give you a little high level
overview of those interactions they're
really the the navigator for a person
incarcerated when somebody is booked
into our system a case manager starts on
the moment they meet with them and says
what do you need to do to find your path
to parole to find your path out of this
institution and even for the 180 people
who won't leave our Institution what are
you going to do for your own betterment
while you're here um and they do that
annually and update those plans at any
rate and pace of the information changes
within our electronic
system the following page represents
also psychotherapeutic programs uh
excuse me they're not therapeutic they
are um delivered by non-clinicians that
we offer within our department to
improve people's social emotional
learning and other coping skills and
factors that result resulted in their
incarceration so I'll leave that to you
as well
we have a robust Educational Service
this is the statute that created the
correction Special School District we're
the only Corrections Department with a
certified high school and we should be
proud of that other Corrections
departments um when they have a
Corrections teacher it is a Corrections
teacher our teachers are certified by
our Department of Education are
qualified to teach in our normal High
School uh systems um we deliver programs
so that people can attain their High
School uh diploma and we will invite you
to those graduations they are Prof found
I'm a tough lady even I've teared up
there um and they are impactful um and
we like to really celebrate those
moments whether somebody is 65 getting
that high school diploma or 25 in
addition we um support people to get
their high school equivalency in New
Hampshire that is called the highet and
then we have a robust Career Technical
education program that helps individuals
and I've already moved two slides ahead
um probably four slides ahead so there's
more detail the Career and Technical
education Center really is the next step
after your Base education which is to
help build those employment and
Vocational opportunities uh again we
opened a licensed cosmetology program
during the pandemic we continue to open
it and now we've Advanced it and we're
opening a barbering program that just
started at our Men's prison and
conquered um we look for all types of
opportunity and continue to look for
opportunities to connect people to
employment and really uh wonderful
occupational release uh because we know
that reduces uh reincarceration ation
and improves people period um we have
been working with White Mountains
Community College and I can't say any
more positive things about White
Mountains Community College to provide
under the second chance pel Grant
opportunity people with access to
college level degrees uh we started at
our Northern New Hampshire correctional
facility and are working with them even
in our Southern tiered facilities as
well as partners at nhti and the
Southern New Hampshire University and so
we really uh thank the legislature for
passing the commission that looks at
education in Corrections and that's
really moved forward and we look forward
the first report was published so that
is available as
well incarceration infects families so
I've also included an infographic on our
family connection center so you can see
the number of individuals we're
supporting both in uh partnership with
the DCF and reconnecting parents through
their programs uh to be effective
parents for their children when they've
lost that right in custody uh as well as
uh General opportunities for individuals
to improve their parenting skills their
visitation and uh communication skills
through uh video contacts that are
supervised and other creative outlets
and structured curriculum um that
program also demonstrates its
Effectiveness in reducing
reincarceration
what would be Corrections if we didn't
talk a little bit about religious
services and the religious land use uh
incarcerated persons act uh we I wanted
to highlight the number of spiritual
Services we support it is Tiny writing
so I'll get it to you in digital format
so you can zoom in um but we've uh my
spiritual leaders across the
organization do do a robust job and I
can't say enough about the volunteers
that come into our institutions and help
support Pathways to uh spiritual health
and I think that's an important overlay
for people if it's something they want
then we want to make sure it's available
to them because we do find it really
helps people again stop returning to
incarceration I hope you heard my theme
about stopping returning to
incarceration uh because we're going to
head to probation and
parole the next slide is an infographic
that gives you um the average case loads
for 2023 and 2024 by district office
I've spent most of my tenure trying to
uh sh the sh the ship in this area uh we
as I indicated we want to partner
effectively with our Judiciary and those
specialty courts but the department uh
didn't get any additional probation and
parol off offers so I balanced using the
state's reallocation process to create
more probation and Par officers to
equalize their case loads when I took
over bless you their case loads were one
to 100 or more in some cases it was one
probation appr officer to 125 supervises
the national um the national statistics
to meet is 1 to 55 uh and that also
depends on the risk of the case load of
the persons they're supervising so I
hope I said that right um so we give you
what our levels of supervision are and
um we have reduced those case loads
closer to the national average there are
a couple other district offices that
exist today where some of those uh
ratios are 1 to 80 and we're still
working to to correct that process uh
through our own means uh but with the
passage of veterans court uh we don't
have additional staff and we're trying
to figure out how to uh navigate support
that
process uh the next slide does get a
little bit more detailed so you can read
it better the types of supervision
across the state and then detailed
description of case load by type of
supervision by location across the state
are the next following slides so to the
point of the
question the research done by the
Council of state governments um and its
interpretation we don't have a high
parole violation rate uh so when you
look at the number of individuals on
parole supervision there's approximately
uh just over
2,000 it's not a high number of those on
supervision that are coming back but it
is somewhere around the 1% of those
people that come back annually affecting
the beds that we use in the prison
system so I just want to be clear
there's not a high parole violation rate
but the number that comes back takes up
about 40% of those beds so um I just
don't want everyone to think that our
pration parole officers are just
violating parole all the time so with
that stated you're going to see a graph
that looks like this and what that is is
a summary of The Adult Parole board's uh
revocation reasons about revocation of
parole and those things are around
returning to criminal Behavior
engagement in substance use um usually
that's uh multiple relapses lack of
compliance with their substance use
treatment plan and then uh commonly
found in possession with the intent to
distribute illegal drugs Pro probation
appr officers are making the right
decisions at the right time to bring
people back to incarceration but what it
tells me is when someone returns I need
to make sure I have the substance use
treatment and those Pathways to
re-engage that process one of the
struggles as articulated both by my
probation parole team and the Adult
Parole Board is granting somebody the
privilege of the parole to go to a
treatment service and they never show up
and they abscond and then they become a
fugitive that doesn't serve any of us
well and we have approximately 300
people right now in a fugitive status on
our case load so I give this information
to you because the work we're doing on
the 1115a waiver is fundamentally simple
if we can get people connected and have
that therapeutic relationship with their
provider before their leave they're very
much more likely to go to the third
appointment and the fourth appointment
and stay compliant with treatment and we
really think that will make a marked
difference in continuing to reduce our
recidivism rate so I see some hands up
uh very briefly on on on that graphic uh
one of the uh uh uh components is uh
revoked for Community failure what's
Community failure that's a great
question uh The Adult Parole Board
basically says all of the assets we
tried to engage with you it didn't
matter what they were it failed you
essentially failed in the
community uh representative m
thank you I'm wondering about what
percentage of people who actually apply
for parole and receive a par parole
hearing actually wind up getting paroled
and is there a lot of variation
depending on the type of crime
representative Muse I would definitely
defer uh that question to The Adult
Parole Board who's an independent uh
body um and I will talk with chairman
Rogers Roger Phillips to make sure we
get that information to you thank you
you're
welcome the uh in anecdotal sense most
individuals are granted the privilege of
parole at their first
hearing represent
Murray thank you Mr chair um I was
curious you know you mentioned that
sexual assault is you know a significant
portion of why people end up in um
incarcerated but then the number of
people um sorry I'm going back to the
page the number of people basically
taking advantage of the uh Services the
behavioral health sex offender treatment
is like a lot lower than I would expect
so I'm just curious like what is the
what is the reasoning behind that people
just not taking advantage of it that's a
great question so the timing of access
to that is around their sentence
structure so those 155 people are in a
Therapeutic Community having uh regular
contacts and we provide people access to
that program based on their earliest
opportunity to release factoring if the
sentencing document says they can get
time off if they complete so if you will
it's a it's an analytical art of moving
them in um that what that line does not
account for is they may show up in those
other lines of service getting other
counseling outside of that specific um
treatment need so they could be seeing
Psychiatry they could also be going to
other mental health groups at the same
time you're
welcome right representative
new thank you Mr chair um I just wanted
to Echo something that you said um I
went to the graduation last year at the
women's facility and it was absolutely
amazing I was in tears I was the only
person who wasn't you know staff member
or family um but it really made a huge
difference to me so I would just suggest
to everyone else that if you when you
get that invitation it's something that
I highly recommend taking advantage of
thank you and with that being said if
you've completed your presentation I
just wanted to um know if we would be
welcome to set up another tour for the
new members to come by the facilities
100% but I would not be done if I didn't
tell you the best
news so the last page of your
presentation shows the road map uh to
reducing our recidivism and uh leave it
with you to show you initiated programs
by year and the changes and shifts in
people's return to incarceration these
are when people are released in 2018 we
track them uh for 3 years post their
releas release and to see if they return
and a lot of the initiatives that we've
started really targeted that first year
prior to release to reduce people's
reincarceration rate uh and we've we've
done an excellent job taking it from 48%
when I started down to the average of
40% um and we continue to analyze why
people come back but we also continue to
analyze why people are successful and so
we'll we'll continue to pass that
information onto this body as you think
about the work that we do in New
Hampshire but we're making marked
strides we're doing excellent job but
I'm very proud of this New Hampshire
Department of Corrections and I want to
thank you for that support um and yes
chairman we would love to offer a tour
uh Jane will be our Lea on to that and
we'll take you through um those
facilities uh that you choose some like
to just see the Men's prison some would
like to see the women's prison and I
want to assure you we're making a good
stride with the monies that were
allocated to do the work the base work
to replace the N Hampshire state prison
for men the first uh trunch of $10
million is in contract and they are
doing all of the geological analysis of
the property behind the New Hampshire
correctional facility for women and I'm
working with our partners at Public
Works to get out a request for proposal
on the other 40 million that was
authorized all great news to hear thank
you very much and thank you for coming
today we really appreciate it and I'm
sorry we held you so long oh you're no
aping necessary thank you thanks thank
you um let me see who do we have next
Attorney Alverson
here if anyone else is here that's going
to speak to us that's in a rush or they
have a deadline just raise your hand
other
okay good morning uh my name is Stephen
endes I'm actually not attorney
Halverson attorney Halverson is my boss
he's the marrat County Attorney he
couldn't make it today um but I am here
from marrat County the County attorneys
each county has a county attorney's
office and the county attorney's office
is prosecute
all the felonies for the county in the
absence of the Attorney General so as
attorney valard said the Attorney
General's office prosecutes homicides U
Medicaid fraud elder abuse some of those
things essentially all the other
felonies are prosecuted by the county
attorney's offices within each
County in addition there as you heard
from Chief Justice McDonald there's
circuit courts where misdemeanors
violations are
prosecuted a lot of the county
attorney's offices also appear in
Circuit Court um to prosecute those
misdemeanor and violation level offenses
on behalf of certain towns so for
example in maramont County the towns of
I know like chiester canbury hopkington
um Bradford Newberry New London contract
with the county attorney's office and we
do their misdemeanor prosecution um
other towns for example conquer has its
own Municipal prosecutor's office that
prosecutes misdemeanors in Circuit Court
um in addition to Prosecuting criminal
cases felonies and misdemeanors we also
handle everything within those cases for
example if competency is raised that
something our office would
handle uh we would follow up if a person
was found for example not competent to
stand trial but was dangerous because of
a mental illness we would follow up and
do the uh non-emergency involuntary
admission at probate court for those
people as well so I'm I'm happy to
answer any questions I'm a a frequent
person here in front of the committee
which I think is a result of geography
in the sense that all the County
attorneys talk but since we're in
conquered it's easier for us to come
over and talk um I personally have
prosecuted in both circuit court and
Superior court for a number of years so
I'm happy to to give you some insight
sort of the view from the ground of that
um and we do all I should point out that
the County attorneys we do talk to each
other we talk to the Circuit Court
prosecutors and get input on uh a lot of
our input and conversation to the
committee and I can tell you the
committee is grateful for your frequent
appearances here they have been very
enlightening and you're a good source um
for for us to bounce some of our crazy
ideas off thank you yeah M uh go ahead
representative Sher thank you
uh just as a matter of education for
those who are new to this committee and
haven't haven't had any experience in
their criminal justices county
attorney's offices are funded on a
county level not at the state level
correct the the county attorney's
offices are funded by the
county any questions for attorney Enders
thank you very much I'm sure we'll see
you shortly yes I'll be
back uh I see one of our sheriffs out
there would you like to come up
Sheriff good good morning chairman and
members of this committee I'm Sheriff
Bill Wright I'm the sheriff elected
Sheriff of bellnap County I'm also the
elected president of the New Hampshire
Sheriff's Association which is made up
of all 10 of us sheriffs across the
state a few things about the sheriff's
Association is we meet monthly um all
the sheriffs that are available we meet
down at the police academy on the third
Thursday at 10:00 a.m. uh we always
invite uh you folks and anybody else who
wants to attend and interact with the
sheriff's offices uh to to be part of
that uh we talk about legislation
upcoming legislation legislation that
we'd like to uh have drafted and brought
forward we talk about uh the different
things that are happening across our
communities and things that happen
because each community of course is
different uh but we all have a lot of
commonality so we try to share resources
and keep a line of communication open uh
it is our office is a uh political
office so uh we come with different
views not all of us have the same views
and it helps us work through some of the
uh intricate problems of our communities
basically that's that's uh that's what
we do uh we are you know the oldest
former law enforcement here in the state
so we take great pride in that and our
Duties are found our duties and
responsibilities are found in RSA 104
and uh and then we we do uh work with
other rsas as well uh as we're uh added
to that we'd like to have conversations
about the different legislation that's
being drafted or thought about uh before
it becomes uh you know a full-blown uh
Bill and then we come in and then we we
look at it a little bit uh deeper uh
because we look at how it's going to
affect so you may put something in there
about a police officer or uh um
conservation officer or something like
that uh but there might be implications
to the Sheriff's offices as well uh so
we we do a deep dive into that have
discussions and and uh we most certainly
don't want to come before this committee
uh with cards uh against uh some of the
legislation but of course we we do at
times now I've testified uh before this
Committee in the past i' I'm in my third
term so I've been here a couple times uh
representing both myself uh as the
sheriff of BNP County and as um previous
uh Secretary of the uh Sheriff's
Association and uh and again
conversation is key and and uh we want
to work through this stuff so we invite
you to be part of that conversation uh
if you choose uh we want to be uh
Advocates to to the criminal justice
system and uh and talk about these
things bail reform I know is always uh
big um the different areas of you know I
listen to the the uh uh commissioner of
the Department of Corrections um you
know the things when people get released
on uh probational parole a lot of times
the the cases will end up back at the
super Court which will result in
warrants which then my office has to
deal with so um these are all things
that you know each part is connected so
uh we are officers of Superior Court uh
and we are constitutional officers uh
based on the New Hampshire Constitution
so uh we take people's rights very
serious and and that's what you find
from our Sheriff's Office I can take
questions if you have
any um would you uhu appreciate it if
members had questions about laws that
may implicate the sheriffs if they
contacted you before they drafted
legislation and if so can you give uh
leave a contact information for people
yes we would definitely appreciate the
conversation um again you you can draft
legislation as you choose um and we
would never stop that but uh being part
of the conversation at least we can give
you the Insight of where we we it on it
or or maybe a different Viewpoint that
you might not recognize as your as as
your intent um and again sometimes it's
just a few extra words in there that
really make the difference uh the
difference between us uh supporting that
and us not supporting it um and again
we're we're a small factor in this but
uh but we are a factor and it does
affect us so uh we do appreciate that
conversation thank you Sheriff any
questions for the
sheriff yes go ahead represent no I just
have a comment just it' be good for the
new legislators to understand that all
of us are the legislative body that
approve County budgets and I didn't
learn that for a long time yeah that's
true as our second everyone who's a new
representative you also know that you're
part of the county delegation and you uh
we vote on the sheriff's budgets and
matter of fact I think I just got
appointed to the chairman of the our
sheriff in Rockingham so yeah um we we
appreciate your support and again
conversation is key we'll we'll be more
than happy one thing about offices we
try to be as effective and as efficient
as we most certainly can and we we
answer to you folks uh as our as our
delegate members and uh and we are
accountable you know for every penny in
our budget and when we uh when we need
extra money we go before you to uh to
ask for that extra money and uh so again
conversation is key uh we want smaller
budgets as well as you do and we're
taxpayers just like everyone else in
this room and uh but again Effectiveness
and uh and and that's what I ask of my
delegation members um before you start
cutting and and and all that uh ask
yourself am I efficient and am I
effective and if the answer is yes then
let's talk about why I need the increase
thank you thank
you me see who we get
left um the Hampshire Public Defenders
here oh there
okay my name is Suzanne kage I'm the
interim executive director of the New
Hampshire Public Defenders I took on
this role 7 days ago however I was a
public defender uh for 15 and a half
years I left the public defenders in
2021 to start my own practice I retired
in June from that practice and now I'm
here I also worked at the Attorney
General's office in the consumer
protection and an antitrust Division I
want to start I wish that Chief McDonald
was still here because I really would
like to have thanked him personally for
bringing to the commission the crisis
that we're having right now in the
public defender program in New Hampshire
for those of you that are new and aren't
familiar with how the criminal justice
system works in the state the sixth
amendment requires that if the state
charges you with a
crime and you could lose your Liberty
and go to jail as a result of being
convicted of that crime the state has to
give you an attorney to represent you if
you can't afford to have one
yourself that's where the public
defenders come in we are one of the few
states that the public defender program
is operated as an independent we're a
nonprofit Law Firm the only people we
represent the our only client is is the
state of New Hampshire we get a contract
every two years from the state to
provide all the indent events across the
state so it's a big job we cover all the
counties as you've heard before there
are 11 Superior Courts 17 circuit courts
we have 28 circuit 28 specialty courts
we have 140 attorneys on a good day that
might change because we've lost three
already the case loads are crushing this
is a national issue and it's affecting
New Hampshire it's particularly
affecting our North Country so those of
you that represent Coos County or
Grafton County we're in a crisis mode
right now trying to find public
defenders that will work in those areas
because they're rural um last year in
well in 2023 we don't have the numbers
for 2024 yet but in 2023 we handled
21322 cases Criminal
cases with 140
lawyers who are driving all over the
state to courts in all all of the
different
locations what we we do not Advocate or
testify on behalf of laws we have a
board of directors that oversees us they
do any kind of advocating as far as
testifying goes to to this
committee and we also are under to the
um supervision our budget particularly
with the judicial Council I think we're
one of the few branches that have asked
for significant increase because of the
crisis that we're facing we cannot have
people sitting in jail without having
legal
representation so we are taking we don't
like to just complain about issues we're
working on mitigation as well to get
more attorneys our pay scale for public
defenders is not where it needs to be
because the work is hard and grueling
and we're losing a lot of lawyers
particularly young ones and older ones
because they're just burning out the
average case loads right now across the
state are running close to 100 and
that's just not ex it's not manageable
it's not something that can be
maintained so some of the mitigation
effects that we're working on and we
welcome any suggestions from anybody
that could have particular suggestions
we're looking at trying to hire lateral
attorneys across the state or outside of
the state to come to New Hampshire
particularly in the rural areas because
if we reach out to Colorado or we reach
out to Wyoming they may we may be able
to poach lateral attorneys that are
experienced and want to live in more
rural
communities we're looking at we do I
noticed earlier that I don't recall who
one of you asked the question regarding
uh do we work with UNH School of Law
thank you chairman I've met with them
this week uh we do work with them they
have an excellent criminal clinic and
they take cases for us they're Limited
in the number of CA these are students
so they can't have heavy case lows but
we we are working closely with them as
well we are um considering asking the
Supreme Court to change rule 36 and what
that is it's a rule that allows
people that are like third year law
students that aren't members of the bar
yet but they can practice in court under
the supervision of a bar attorney in the
state if we can get laterals coming from
other states and it takes a while I'm
not sure what the process is to wave in
or take the bar in New Hampshire but if
we could adjust it to perhaps
accommodate exper when I when I say
lateral attorneys I'm talking about
experienced attorneys the public
defenders are usually staffed by Young
attorneys coming out of law school that
want to do public service work but when
you have case loads this High you really
need to have enough experienced
attorneys to be able to mentor and train
the younger attorneys to be able to take
on more
cases so those are the mitigation issues
we're working on right now to try to
bring solutions to the table regarding
this issue um
as far as the consequences of the laws
that are passed by this commission our
responsibility in administration is to
keep all of our attorneys informed of
any laws that are passed criminal laws
any changes to the laws and what sort of
collateral effects those laws might have
because when you pass a law for instance
as an example armed career criminal
which was passed many decades
ago the collateral issues of that are
it's a mandatory sentence and when I say
mandatory it means that a judge has no
discretion in determining what the
sentence should be we don't have that
many mandatory sentence in mandatory
sentences in the state but that's one
that's a particular issue because it
eliminates any kind of discretion that a
judge can have and I can get into more
details if anybody has questions about
that or thefts for instance
when the law was passed that a third
theft we're talking shoplifting can be
charged as a
felony and a felony is anything that
results in prison time so a misdemeanor
is anything that can result up to 12
months in jail and a felony as was
stated earlier is anything that goes
over that 365 days and that would
require that they go to
prison so a law such as what we would
call a three strikes law law where two
shopliftings lead to misdemeanors but
you get a third shoplifting that can be
a
felony which changes the workload of the
attorney and also affects court dockets
across the state that those are the
things that we are dealing with right
now um I don't have a packet to hand out
yes
so um thank you I I I have to admit that
um uh much to uh the sh of of uh Miss K
she's a former student of mine
so she she carries that through her life
unfortunately
um what's the starting pay three
questions what's the starting pay for a
public
defender I am reluctant to give any
specifics because this is my seventh day
on the job I believe it's in the
and and again this is with the caveat I
can provide all this information upon
request that's more definitive 67,000 I
believe thank you and it caps out uh
second question
um several years ago uh a combination of
uh legislation and Court rule uh the the
court was obligate the courts are
obligated to appoint councel before
somebody is arraigned my understanding
so that they have on a on a on a
misdemeanor to which they're entitled to
Council of Class A misdemeanor and a
felony um it's my understanding that
that's just because of Staffing reasons
that's been a struggle uh for the public
defender program is is that getting any
better or is
that I want to say thank you for that
question I'm sure I'm not sure
actually arraignments are a big issue I
have spent two of the last three days
talking to several of the managing
attorneys throughout the state and the
arraignments are causing a major problem
um there are you can be arrested for a
misdemeanor offense and cash bail is is
requested or cash bail is put into
effect you have to have an attorney if
you especially at that point if you if
you're going to go to jail for a
misdemeanor a lot of the arraignments
are being done by video and you have to
have in the old days let's say you
didn't necessarily have an attorney
there at that point that's not the case
anymore so you're correct um but that is
a big issue that I've discovered in the
last seven days is the system for
arraignments for incarcerated
misdemeanor clients is severe and I
don't know what the solutions are or if
it's getting better for that matter and
and Fa one last thing and and just a
comment uh decades ago now when I was a
public defender uh I managed a couple
offices and we never had lawyers in our
offices with case loads of over 55 even
the more senior lawyers and that's a uh
just to give the members of the
committee a sense of how acute the
problem is right now it's acute
throughout the country and some states
are going through uh litigation Maine in
particular they didn't have a public
defender program um Idaho other states
are being
I'm not going I I again I'm hesitant to
say with spec specificity but legal
actions are taking against certain
States because the public defender
programs are in such a crisis that you
have people sitting in jail for a long
period of time without a lawyer New
Hampshire I would
say I still believe is we're a small
state so I think we have a a way of
putting our arms around crisises that
bigger States can't do and I think we we
have a very good program we have we're
now we're known throughout the country
as a great place to get trained that's
still in effect that's still our
reputation that we TR we do we do not
just hire an attorney and throw them
into a courtroom that doesn't do anyone
any any good we train them for six weeks
we give them mentors and then we send
them out there Co caused a big
disruption and a lot of that a lot of
the younger attorneys didn't get that
Hands-On colle
one-on-one training that they would have
gotten during Co because everything went
remote so I'm trying to determine how
much of an impact that might have
had representative the
South thank you thank you for taking my
question uh might be a little bit unfair
because of uh you've been in the
position such a short time but there is
a pool of experience against attorneys
who might not have Roots anywhere in the
country I'm speaking in terms of
veterans who are uh getting out of uh
the military uh JAG officers who have
significant uh uh legal background who
might be looking to relocate to uh uh
New Hampshire because we have so much to
offer I'm just wondering if in the
public defender office are there any e
efforts to reach out and
recruit uh veterans that is a very good
suggestion and that is exactly the type
of thing that I'm looking for as the
Director um and I don't know the answer
to that but that's what I will be
finding out in the next two days and
determining if we're doing that um a lot
of a lot of the and there there's a
great pool of attorneys in the state
that are criminal defense attorneys but
to so we would get the first assign
councel goes to the public defenders if
they're Indigent and if we have a
conflict then it goes to a different
group we have contract attorneys
contract attorneys take and there may be
some
some veterans on in our amongst our
whole I know we have veterans that are
public defenders in the state I'll look
into that but just to
explain so we take the first case if if
we are not conflict we take all the
criminal cases for Indigent defendants
if there's a conflict we have a contract
attorney group they actually have a
contract with the state to take a
certain amount they don't have to take
the cases but they have a contract to
take cases if we give them the cases
then we have another group called
assigned councils assigned Council don't
have any um contracts but they take
cases at a higher rate than the contract
Council makes which doesn't make a lot
of sense when you think about it and
even those rates are
low top of my head I'm saying $125 an
hour $100 an
hour the cases that we are dealing with
in the state and that's been referenced
several times are very complicated we
have a lot of sexual assault cases those
are extremely complicated cases to
manage um homicides have gone up those
are very difficult cases we work with
the attorney generals on that um we have
a high degree of mental health issues
among our clients clients have become
much more needier than in the last 10
years a lot of homeless population a lot
of mental health issues with those homes
f a lot of drug addiction that all
complicates the the cases and electronic
Discovery electronic Discovery is
just made and I would say across the
aisle the YDC case was referenced
earlier there are over a million pages
of
Discovery and case and in my private
practice I actually had one of those
cases and I don't any longer because I I
left my practice so the comp the issues
among the workload and and I'm I'm sorry
representative I didn't answer your
question but I would like to find out
myself now that you've brought that up
how many veterans we do have that may be
in the public defenders and how we could
reach out to others that are looking to
expand their legal career or go into
this type of work
follow up Mr
chairman uh one of the things that I'm
sure you struggle with is to have a
public defenders office that re uh
reflects the racial and ethnic uh uh uh
community that you
represent in New Hampshire I'm
sure um
recruiting minorities is very difficult
by expanding the pool of applicants to
include veterans you would significantly
help in that regard so thank you it's
not a question I'm just I I very much
appreciate the insight and the input
though in that because we are struggling
with retaining and you want to a good
point of contact would be uh ad the
state agitant General's office they can
put you in touch with people in the
Department of Defense who would be able
to um maybe you could put some type of
an ad together for retiring dog
Jacks representative
Newman um do you expect that there would
be any impact from the new magistrate
law that's been passed for arraignments
and stuff like that do you have any
thoughts on that I am not able to answer
that question right now as I said
arraignments went up to the top of my
list within the last two days because of
the input I'm getting from the
attorneys okay thank you for coming to
today and Sharon with us and if you have
any more updates we'd be happy to hear
them as you are here a little bit longer
yes and well I'll be here for quite a
while and I think that if anybody has
any questions regarding the process feel
free to reach out to me we will thank
you everybody thank you very
much um do we have uh Chief Crowley
thank you Mr chairman excuse me my name
is Tim Carley I'm the chief in the town
of ainson I'm here representing uh the
New Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police as I was recently elected uh
president and um a position that I um I
I feel very fortunate to have um the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police represents 194 different police
departments across the state of New
Hampshire we have 165 active
members uh we meet as a general body
every other month we meet as an
executive uh committee every uh on the
months that we don't meet with the full
membership our our purposes are
multifaceted one we want to maintain a
focus on
keeping the profession in the state of
New Hampshire um of the the level that
it's at right now when you come from
another state and you see what the
standard is to be a law enforcement
officer in New Hampshire you realize how
high that standard is and we do
everything in our power to maintain that
uh that standard and make sure that
we're always using best practices when
we uh recruit we hire we train uh and we
we try to retain uh the officers that
are working out there because it's very
important it's a great job it's the best
job in the world um but it's it comes
with a lot of challenges
um so as an organization when we meet we
have perspectives from a town like
ainson which is small and then you get
the perspective from Chiefs and command
level people from a conquor a Manchester
or an asash to hear the issues that uh
of concern to them because a lot of
times we see the same things small town
large community just at a different
volume so our our job is is very
complicated
we do a lot of different things one of
the most important parts of the
organization is working with committees
like this in legislation because our
primary focus is to keep New Hampshire
one of the safest if not the safest
state in the country to live it and
that's that comes with a lot of
responsibility because uh we we don't
police the state of New Hampshire we
protect the state of New Hampshire and
there's a fine line to that so as an
organization that's what we try to do
and it's not always easy um and it's
always up for discussion because we have
different perspectives and it it's great
to be able to one of the things that
I've learned and I've only been here
since 18 and part of this organization
but coming to the state house or going
to different committee meetings is the
ability and the willingness of people to
listen and to work together and to come
up with Solutions when it's a challenge
because our perspective of what we see
in your perspective of what you see are
different in a lot of
cases in in the experience that's part
of this organization uh can't be
replaced you have I mean I'm I'm in year
42 and you have um some officers that
have been on less than 10 years that are
now Chiefs or commanders in their
organizations so as much as you get
changes in technology and scrutiny and
um ways of solving crimes when a crime
commits you got to go out and you got to
solve it you got to work with evidence
you got to work with the science and you
got to come up with a uh somebody and
hold them responsible for what they did
and that's all all well and good but our
primary focus is trying to prevent that
crime from happening in the first place
so that's what we do and when we meet
that's what we try to maintain that
Focus so from the hiring Personnel to
get the right people on the job training
them and always updating that and
maintaining the high level of standard
that New Hampshire has that's uh that's
what our organization does and it's it's
interesting to see um and listen to
people who have been in different
agencies or different situations whether
they've been in training or uh lawyers
and in um it it's it's been a great
learning experience and I really look
forward to this year um because we want
to maintain that high quality of life of
the State of New Hampshire and I'd be
willing to take any questions or
comments
uh thank you Chief um I I I asked this
question um I I am finishing up a term
as police commissioner in Portsmouth and
we are in the process of of implementing
a body camps in Portsmith it was a long
time coming but we're doing that do you
have a so two questions do you have a
any sense of how many departments in New
Hampshire now have body camps and second
question is what if anything can the
legislature do to uh encourage other uh
particularly smaller departments that
don't have them to get
them um I don't have an exact percentage
I know that it grows every year you see
more departments with them and at some
point we will have them I I think
they're a great tool um one of the
things that kept smaller agencies from
doing it is the expense and and not to
get into a body cam discussion but
buying the camera
is the least of the cost it's the
storage and the redaction um I worked in
the city of LOL before I came up here
the middle sex County district attorney
said if you people go to body cams which
they've since gone to I will have to
hire five additional Adas just to do
video storage redaction and what
presentation so there's a lot of
companies now there's little more
competition so the the cost is coming
down um I think if there's grant
opportunities
for um for smaller agencies like ourself
I mean we could buy it now but then to
maintain it um it's it's it's cost
prohibitive right now but the cost is
coming down because the competition is
going up thank you you're
welcome thank you Chief thank you very
much we'll see you at some point
throughout the year I'm sure oh no doubt
thank you thanks um
we have let me see from the ACLU um
Amanda aad is she here
oh thank you everybody um chairman
members of the committee this is my
first time speaking in the L so I am new
as of this summer to the ACLU of New
Hampshire Amanda aad I'm the policy
director I was previously in the past
with the ACLU of Arizona um very happy
to be here prefer the weather um over
over the desert for sure I'm going to
keep it very brief and I have business
cards I'm happy to chat with anyone or
connect you all with other folks in our
office if that's ever
helpful um I just want to give a very
brief overview of what the ACLU is the
American civil liberties Union um and
then just show my face get to see you
all um looking forward to being here in
the future um so the ACLU itself is an
organization that's been around for over
a 100 years um the ACLU of New Hampshire
was founded in the
60s we are a
nonprofit uh nonpartisan organization
that does not accept any government
funding
um we are also importantly to note a
membership organization so we have over
150 U million members as of now and we
preserve the individual rights and
Liberties guaranteed by the Constitution
so we like to think of the Bill of
Rights in the Constitution as our
client so we have different buckets of
work a lot of which you will all see but
much of it you will not see here at the
legislature um so we of course do
litigation something that's we're very
well known for um we've gone for example
to the Supreme Court more than any other
organization except for the Department
of Justice um so we are certainly an
organization with many many attorneys we
also do legislative advocacy we also do
importantly education in the community
know your rights um so that individuals
can represent themselves they can
advocate for thems and they understand
their rights under the law lastly we do
a lot of organizing Within the community
again we think it's really important for
individuals to be able to protect
themselves and stand up for
themselves so we focus on equality and
fighting discrimination for over a
hundred years that goes from the
Japanese internment cases to segregation
in schools and interracial marriage um
to the different issues that we're
seeing today one of the really big
issues that we're going to come before
this Committee in particular and talk
about is mass incarceration um of the
speakers today have addressed that issue
um it's something that's been really
overwhelming for some time
now um we care deeply about defending
the rights of those coming in contact
with the criminal legal system so there
are many many different issue areas
within the criminal justice system that
we address um mass
incarceration being at the top of the
list government overreach um government
transparency is very important to us due
process pre-trial confin
um the list goes on racial disparities
and much much more I just want to flag
some very basic things and then I'll let
you um chat with everyone else waiting
here today um the US currently spends
over 80 billion dollar on
incarceration um and that is just a
mind-blowing number and I don't know the
exact dollar amount for New Hampshire
but I'm sure we spend a great deal um
some related work that all might have
questions about in the future is uh
privacy and Technology we cover that
free speech is something that we're best
known for and very proud of um we do
immigrants rights Juvenile Justice and
many other issues we have defended many
controversial and unpopular groups um
because we believe strongly in the right
to free expression and free assembly and
other constitutional rights and we are
proud of that um once the government has
the power to violate one person's rights
um can be use that power against anyone
and everyone and that's something that
we think of quite a bit in our office
here in New
Hampshire
um so one of our main concerns we
incarcerate our people more than any
other country by far um for just to put
this in context we are 5% of the world's
population here in the United States we
are more than 20% of the people who are
in prison um so it's just truly
mindboggling when you look at the data
and the numbers around incarceration
um I myself I'm happy to meet with any
of you all and I hope to get to know you
while we work together going forward um
I've covered a lot of unique issues from
religious freedom something that's also
very important to the ACLU I've worked
with uh tribal students native students
on being able to wear tribal regalia at
school graduations um I've done
litigation surrounding First Amendment
and protesting um prison conditions and
the right to Medical Care and pregnancy
and postpartum supplies while
incarcerated is something that's been
really important um and addressing
disparities and school ARR rest and
discipline so thank you for letting me
get up here and share um just getting
over a little bit of a cold myself um so
I appreciate being able to have some of
your time I'll leave these here if
anybody wants to reach out so thank you
very
much okay
and last but certainly not least um Pam
colleague with the um
Coalition oh
dear two Seer good morning Mr chairman
and members of the committee um my name
is Amanda GR ston and I am the director
of public affairs for the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence and I am joined by uh Pamela
kyg who is our public policy specialist
and one of the best hires that I've ever
made um by way of background I um am a
city counselor here in cocher New
Hampshire and I chair our Public Safety
Advisory Board and I've also been with
the New Hampshire Coalition um since
2001 as an intern that I've been um
spending time coming before this
committee and before I um turn things
over to Pamela to give you an overview
of the Coalition and our member programs
um and uh you know uh more information
about ways that we can assist you as a
committee I just wanted to um
congratulate all of you for being
appointed to this committee I think it's
a very important Committee in the house
um polling in New Hampshire consistently
shows that Public Safety is one of the
most important things to your
constituents having a safe State safe
communities and a safe home are their
top priority and so um we thank you all
for your service here and um again
congratulations on your elections
re-elections and being on this very
important committee you
Pamela thank you Amanda thanks everyone
um it's really um great to be back in
this committee um I have had the
privilege of being being able to work
with you over the years I think this is
my sixth uh legislative session um I
know they go by really quickly um but we
are just so grateful to be able to work
with you um from year to year on these
critical issues like Amanda said I'm the
public policy specialist at the
Coalition um but we do have a team um
that keeps an eye on legislation and you
also will probably see some of our
program um uh colleagues who work on
issue areas that I'll highlight in a
little bit um throughout the session as
well um so so we um are the um the
umbrella Organization for the 12 U
member programs across the state who
operate crisis centers and Emergency
Shelters um and cover issues of domestic
violence sexual assault stalking child
abuse and human trafficking um and so we
are you know very present in this
committee um and I've brought um some
materials that I'll pass around to all
of you um just to highlight a few key
statistics um a handout specifically on
the cost of trauma I know we just heard
a little bit about the cost of
incarceration but I think the other side
of the coin is the cost of victimization
um so I think that's a really helpful
handout just to know that there's a
lifetime cost that comes especially for
those abused as children um but even
into adulthood um and an economic impact
that we have not only on individuals but
on the state and uh country as well um
as well as a policy brief on human
trafficking I know that's a really big
issue area um and so we are happy to
highlight that um and a few other
materials as well so hopefully they'll
be helpful to you all um but we are just
grateful to be a resource um so as I
mentioned we're the umbrella
Organization for the 12 member programs
um and one of our biggest roles as the
Coalition is working on Statewide policy
work um and we uh really pride ourselves
in collaborating with a variety of
stakeholders um many of whom you are uh
heard today um in this room presenting
um so State agencies um nonprofit and
advocacy organizations as well as
healthc Care Professionals Law
Enforcement Officers legal
Representatives Advocates and then also
uh victims and survivors so uh we really
try to work across um you know the
entire spectrum of folks that may be
impacted by these issues um and try to
be as collaborative as possible um and I
think this is one of the rare issues um
the Amanda mentioned that really has
broad bipartisan support and tremendous
public support for victims of crime in
the state um and as a result we have
some of the strongest laws and protocols
in the nation um and that's all a part
of the great work that you all do here
and just the dedication to these issues
um and so you know we just really
appreciate you know the hard work that
you do in this committee um when we
bring forward legislation or when we
weigh in on proposals we really try to
be um you know as as careful as we can
when we're vetting these things um
usually when we're testifying we've
already run it by several other
stakeholders um just to get a sense of
you know what not only what the the the
principle of the policy is but how that
is going to implement on the ground um
because I think implementation and
enforcement of policies is the most
fundamental part of doing um impactful
work in the state um so we really try to
heavily vet all of these proposals and
just um be great resource if we don't
have the answers um we are happy to find
the right person uh to sit in front of
you to help guide um and and provide
that information um and I think it's
just really important that um we try to
come with a very balanced perspective um
we want to make sure that Public Safety
um is at the core of what we do um and
we aren't trying to tip the scales of
Justice um because there are victims of
Domestic and Sexual Violence um but
they're also savvy abusers who know to
operate within the system um and it's
important to really look holistically at
these processes um so we're not just
here yes we're here advocating on behalf
of victims and our crisis centers um but
we really just want the most effective
and efficient system that we possibly
can have in New Hampshire um and so
that's why this is just such an
important um process for us
um and then so just kind of like an
overview of our um legislative work and
so please feel free to reach out out um
our cards are in the folders um we are
happy to answer questions happy to help
look into issues um you'll probably see
me here almost every day that you're
meeting um so just please use us we're
happy to be a resource um just to
quickly highlight Our member programs
because they're your resources and the
resources for your constituents um so
like I said um we have these 12 member
programs within this is also our
catchment map um so you can see where
those are located and their contact
information um we serve um our member
programs serve around
15,000 um victims of crime every year um
in addition to doing uh prevention
education in the communities um we also
operate 11 Emergency Shelters um and
those shelters provide shelter to around
400 adults and children annually um so
um they're key part to communities um
crisis centers um provide an array of
services and referrals including access
to confidential Advocates um like I
mentioned emergency shelter and housing
um as well as helping find a placement
um in transitional housing um and just
you know being an immediate resource
they can for folks fleeing uh violence
um as well as economic justice so I
offsetting the costs of any sort of
financial abuse that may occur um as
well as funding uh for immediate basic
needs um many survivors just don't have
groceries or phone cards or gas or rent
um and so we really want to make sure
that them and their children are able to
get those basic needs as quickly as
possible um they also provide safety
planning uh conne connection to legal
services so you heard the Chief Justice
speak this morning um working within the
court um to provide services is a a
fundamental part of the work that they
do um as well as Hospital advocacy and
accomp accompaniment especially in
sexual assault cases um as well as then
just being a connection to Community
Resources such as mental health
substance use treatment um and so on so
um you know our
victims in New Hampshire often um have
you know an array of services that they
need and I think that goes back to the
cost of trauma um that I mentioned
earlier um so the the core thing is
really just making sure that folks have
what they need to get back on their feet
um and be stable in their
communities um I just wanted to quickly
highlight um a couple of our programs um
that I mentioned that are under our
umbrella um so the first one is the um
human trafficking collaborative task
force um so New Hampshire has a
partnership that is dedicated to
improving the Statewide response to
human trafficking um and so the
Coalition helps direct that and um
partners with key stakeholders including
the Department of Justice Homeland
Security um investigation State Police
uh us attorneys crisis center Advocates
um you know legal representatives and so
on um to help ensure that victims of
human trafficking whether it's labor orx
sex trafficking um have the resources
they need but that also we can address
these um horrific cases um and um like I
mentioned there's a policy brief on that
but that's something that if you are
interested in learning more about the
programming and and what that looks like
here in New Hampshire um because it's
everything from you know uh crossborder
you know truck stop um sex trafficking
to unfortunately you know familial
trafficking where we see children um you
know unfortunately being impact Ed by
this um so it looks a little different
but it happens in all corners of the
state unfortunately um so this is a huge
issue we'd be happy to speak more on and
and be a resource on um and then I think
like um the other one that I think is
really uh relevant to your committee is
the sexual assault nurse examiner
program I know um me uh representatives
of that program have come in in the past
to talk about anything related to sexual
assault cases um whether it's um you
know D analysis rape kits uh physical
injuries and things like that so um
those experts um both me um medical
experts are able to come in and talk
more about what they're seeing and how
we can best uh respond to those cases as
well um so I think before I just wrap up
um I just want to remind you that we're
a resource um and we're happy to be here
um to help um and we like really try to
be as responsive as possible so please
call Amanda and I anytime for anything
um we will always make ourselves
available um if you have questions about
a last minute Amendment um help for your
constituents um help understanding
services or help you know with
legislation like we really want to be a
resource for you in whatever way we can
um and are just grateful um you know
that we get to do this work uh with you
all did you have anything no it's
fantastic yeah we're happy to take any
questions thank you so much any
questions I can tell the members that
are new that um they are here a lot and
I enjoy working with them and they're
very helpful um on
legislation um thanks awesome thank
you I believe is there anyone else who
wanted to address committee that hasn't
yet okay
I'll be very quick because I know I'm
between you and lunch um I just wanted
to introduce myself my name is Kate fry
I'm the vice president of advocacy at
new Futures we're a health policy
organization we work on the health and
wellness of New Hampshire residents um
in this particular committee you may see
me or someone else on issues related to
harm reduction substance use disorder um
and um any criminal pen penalties
related to that so I just wanted to um
introduce myself and thank you thank you
for coming up we appreciate it all right
that's going to be our last presenter
for the day I just wanted to go over a
few things with the committee members
that I haven't had a chance to talk to
you
yet those of you who were here last year
you kind of know how I operate those of
you who are new uh may not I'm going to
ask for the same things we did last year
because it was very successful um we are
Democrats and we are Republicans but I
would ask that we maintain between
ourselves and this committee a certain
level of collegial
um and that includes not bashing each
other on social media um on X or where
is it there are plenty of other
Democrats and plenty of other
Republicans that you can bash over the
head on social media um but leave the
ones in this committee alone if you
don't mind um it makes it easier for us
to work together so I would appreciate
that and um I would appreciate that if
you are not going to be here let your
ranking member or myself or the vice
chairman know that you're not going to
be here especially on Executive session
days so that they have a chance to get a
replacement for you and was there
anything
else hold
on oh yeah um when we have people come
in and testify a lot of times we have
victims of crimes come in here and
testify and I know i' we've addressed
this already with Republicans but um if
it's a victim of a crime and or the for
example the mother of someone who was
passed away from a crime I would ask
unless it's absolutely necessary to not
ask them questions let them give their
testimony we will be heartfelt and thank
you very much for sharing and we feel
you know and let them go and I think
that's about it um remember while we're
asking questions in this committee We're
very professional we want to get answers
we don't want no gotas it's just if you
already know the answer don't ask them
it's to elicit information so we want to
do that I run a very kind of loose
committee I like it everyone to talk we
learn more when we talk so I'm not a
real stickler for you know um
necessarily I don't want to say the
rules but I'm not I'm not you know that
I'm not a stickler so if you have a
question you raise your hand I'll let
you go I usually don't stop people I let
them talk um as long as we don't abuse
that I don't have to start using that
stupid Hammer go ahead thank you Mr
chair just wondering if you have a sense
of what days we'll be meeting yeah we're
going to be doing we we have Thursdays
and Fridays and occasional Wednesday
Wednesdays we share with ways and means
they have Monday Tuesdays and occasional
Wednesdays will SP depending on it's a
uh it's a money year so they're going to
have priority so I would like to do just
like I did last year if the people that
weren't here um we got out of here early
um I'd rather stay here in the winter
when it's nasty and be free when the
weather gets nice so we're going to
knock these things out we're going to be
done way before our deadline and we'll
only have to come back for session days
and I hope you guys are agree with
that's the best way to do it I don't
want to hang around here all all all
spring because remember we go to June
and I had us out of here last year when
was it um April we were done yeah so I
want to do that again this year and we
had 50 bills uh representative
Muse one of the the major differences
between this year and uh and the
previous session is uh the the change in
the rules around uh noticing of
executive sessions yeah and I know that
uh
committee chairs have a lot of
discretion I also know that we deal with
some
extremely complicated bills and it one
of the worst one of the worst parts of
being a legislator can be showing up for
a series of hearings on totally
different issues and then immediately
after those hearings have to do an
executive session on a bill you haven't
thought about in three weeks and I I'm
just curious how you intend to kind of
navigate through that this year I I it's
too for me all those gotcha executive
sessions are are too complicated I I I
want to notice them the traditional way
if I put a notice in the calendar that
says executive session may be held then
we may hold it that day but I will let
the ranking member know in the morning
um there's going to be no surprise exact
haha it's not how I operate and
um no laptops DAV yeah I I thought it
might be helpful I know um uh for the
new members to maybe uh meet uh Brad and
maybe get an understanding of why he's
sitting there at that desk typing away
madly and he's like the and how he can
help us all the man behind the
curtain yeah let thank you for that
suggestion Dave um Bradley Greenland
he's um our committee
researcher if you have any questions
about a law that you want to write or
that's coming in this committee he can
find the information for you be it in
this state or another state um or what
we've done on law in the past a lot of
times bills that come in this committee
have actually been here before 10 times
10 years ago and he will be able to look
up and say this is what you guys voted
in the committee back then um anything
else would you like to address
committee for
okay if anyone didn't get that where's
the printing policy you said it should
be at our desk we didn't see
it if you send one to every member so
they understand the printing policy and
how to go about getting amendments that
would be awesome I would appreciate it
um for those of you who's who's new here
totally to the legislature okay so a lot
of what we've been talking about sounds
like a crazy talk I'm sure um if you
have a question about anything about an
amendment about how the process works
you grab one of us and we'll help walk
through it you'll only have to see that
once and you'll be on it so um if you
feel yourself getting overwhelmed or
confused just raise your hand tell me
hey um you're losing me here and I'd be
happy to walk through it um any anyone
else want to bring say
anything
what oh
laptops I don't mind I what I don't want
to see is walls of laptops I know David
has a condition and that's fine if you
need your computer that's fine um if you
need to to get something look up
something what I don't want to see
please is people we I've seen before who
would be doing gotcha stuff like looking
on the thing hey well it says right here
that you did this no um but other than
that you know how I am I'm fine yes I
just want to say I appreciate that
because it's helpful sometimes when
we're talking about a law yeah and it it
goes to a par I mean talking about a
particular law and you need to know how
the bill that affects a particular law
it's easier if you can get access to the
law and then see how to do and that's
what yeah I just while while someone's
testifying I'd rather not see a wall of
laptops but if we're getting into a
exact session or we're looking up
something that's absolutely okay with me
and I really appreciate that no thanks
um what
else it's it's
hard when we're doing it ex when we're
doing an executive I'm sorry we're doing
a hearing if they get my attention and
I'll write their name down so people
oh yeah if you have a question and I'm
focused on the person testifying get
Jen's attention so she or or um Ally my
clerk one of their attentions so I know
that there's a question out there
because I can't see to my left like
David I I won't see him past these
people and the same thing if you have a
question make sure you get one of their
attention and I'll call in you just go
like this I'll I'll acknowledge that I
see you and I'll I'll write your name
down that way you don't have to just
keep on raising your hand or thinking
you're not being seen I'll I'll make eye
contact I I don't think we had any
issues last year unless it was something
I couldn't see but we we do our best to
be able to see that sometimes joh and I
talk behind Terry's back all the time
all the time we actually just kind of
push his head down tell he's in our way
we'll take it if you have a a medical
issue where um like if we're going and
you need to get lunch or something just
make sure you pass the message down that
we need to break and or if you just need
a break sometimes I'll go a couple hours
sometimes I try to take a bio break
every hour hour and a half so that
should everybody okay any other
questions from anybody before I let you
get out of here next week we're going to
here three dayses yeah um I don't think
we got this I don't think we have a no
for Friday there is did everyone get
Friday's notice does no why did she not
send that out I don't know I just I got
Wednesday and Thursday huh yeah she
should have
um just it okay all right well we're
going to be here at least Wednesday
Thursday I scheduled Friday I don't know
why it hasn't been sent
out check your emails that's another
thing if if I send you an email um and
it and I ask a question even if you're
not it doesn't pertain to you if I just
let me know you got the email because
I'll look I'll look at my screen and I'm
not getting responses like if my email
even going out um just keep your eyes on
your email because that's my main
communication
method no I don't care yeah um just no
food while while we're in here on the
tables um you can drink just fine with
me just don't don't be breaking out
sandwiches and stuff yeah and that's it
I'll see you all next week